-Welcome back, everyone.
I am here with Naomi Watts
right there.
Aw, come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
One of our favorites.
Naomi, you've recently learned
how to make pottery for a role.
And you've been posting videos
of your work on Instagram.
And we have everything
we need here.
I've never done this.
I'm so excited about this.
We're both going to make a bowl.
-We hope. Let's try.
Let's not get too attached.
Beautiful accidents --
-A bowl seems like something
that can --
-Anyone can do? I know.
But I have not done 10,000 hours
on the wheel.
I'm not a master.
-Oh, you're not a pottery master
at all.
You're still learning.
-I've done about three hours.
[ Laughter ]
But let's wing it.
-Okay, here we go.
Alright, what do we do?
We got water?
-Wet your hands.
-Wet your hands first.
And then you gently
press the pedal there.
Okay?
-Yep.
-And that'll give you
some speed.
Oh, it's a bit harder
in high heels.
-My sponge has already got
jammed up.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yep, yep. Mine, too.
-Do you need one?
Be careful now.
-So make sure you're nice and --
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-Hold on. Alright, wait.
You're not telling me what
to do, anything at all.
[ Laughter ]
You just said make sure
you're nice --
-Press, press, press. I know.
Okay.
-Make it wet.
-And then, like, just put
your hands gently on it.
Okay, and feel it.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Feel it.
-I feel like -- I feel like
I've already made a bowl.
-Wow, you went straight in.
-I would eat out of this.
Yeah, this is something
I would --
I would eat cereal out of that.
It looks pretty good.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It could also be an ashtray.
You can also do shots from this,
get frocked up if you want.
Whatever you want to do.
-Let me help you.
-Oh.
[ Audience ohs ]
-Okay, I don't want to get this
dirty.
But here, you need to put
your hands around it.
[ Laughter ]
-This is, like -- Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And lean into it.
Yeah, you can close your eyes,
yeah.
-Oh, I was closing my eyes.
-But press the pedal.
-Oh, sorry, sorry,
of course, yes.
How is that?
-And keep it steady
on the pedal.
-Yeah. Am I doing anything else?
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
Whoa, whoa.
[ Laughter ]
Wow. Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Make it -- Oh, whoa.
-What, what?
-Keep the pedal going.
-Oh, keep the pedal going, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And gentle, gentle.
-And my eyes are closed.
I am gentle --
[ Laughter ]
It just came out.
This came out.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's a napkin ring.
We made a napkin ring!
Look at this. It's gorgeous.
She shaped it like there.
-You know, you can actually
put it back on
if you want and then
just start again.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
Start again. Naomi Watts!
"Infinite Storm" is in
select theaters March 23rd.
Start again. We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."
Stick around.
Let me see what you --
Oh, you made a great one.
Oh, my God.
You made a great one.
♪♪